if we've learned anything from that
kendall Jenner commercial it's that any
issue can be exploited for corporate
financial gain with zero negative
repercussions so with Earth Day coming
up it's only natural that a bunch of old
rich dudes would flip the script on
climate change for their own gain so it
might as well be the Koch brothers an
organization funded by the Koch boys are
in the building there they are there's
an organization funded by the right-wing
climate change denying billionaire
turtle men who are involved in over 300
oil spills they want you to celebrate
this Earth Day by celebrating fossil
fuels so the Earth Day fossil fuels art
contest implores us to quote celebrate
the trucks that deliver the trees or the
gas it powers the truck or the plastic
handles of the shovels they use makes no
sense like celebrating Christmas by
stealing Xboxes from orphans doesn't
really make sense look no I'm gonna
steal from the orphans and give to the
rich kids see hello anyway whoever wrote
this is the same person who said stupid
like what can't it be called Father
earth
yes Oh God
the independence Institute is accepting
submissions uh virginal artwork
celebrating fossil fuels until tomorrow
I've already submitted mine all natural
okay how would you celebrate fossil
fuels 70 by putting a plastic bag over
my head and murdering a seagull all
right fine Jesus I'm gonna drive in a
stretch limo to a field full of
endangered pandas all right boy barrel
I'm going to fly my private jet from the
Bronx to Queens all right perfect